watch it I think ago we had chopped off
the ninth episode still watching in it
no no I do I catch up on it now and
again but I really should get the bulks
s is my wife she's not seeing it so I'd
like to sit down with her and say them
all rather than just catching bits here
and there and you don't know that we all
want to watch Ned Stark watch Game of
Thrones right yeah wait till you see it
I mean everything has changed from the
effects of it you know the amount of
money HBO has put behind their amazing
yeah so who would you want to end up on
the Iron Throne if it was up to you but
I know you haven't watched it but good
place to start well you have Daenerys
you have Jon Snow Jaime Lannister Tyrion
Lannister Cersei Lannister guys who
stole good jumps man of Tarth with Jon
Snow be a good choice I don't know I
think he is a good choice yeah I think
that's a chance no yeah I don't want to
spoil anything for you now cuz you
haven't seen it so I can't even tell you
what happened with John Snow last season
right guys I mean come on what you're
his dad well yeah I thought that when I
was doing it they didn't tell me which
is just as well because I treated him as
his son and that's the way it should be
but no I didn't know everybody keeps
asking I don't know what do you think
you know cuz he would that was the idea
wasn't it's not who killed jr. you know
kept it going cotton hey everybody is
Charlie so there was a whole bunch of
new season 8 winds of winter stuff that
just dropped between a couple different
interviews Sean Bean and then separately
George art Martin so this would be a
breakdown for the really big stuff that
they talked about like Sean Bean
revealed what happened when he was
getting beheaded what his last words
were because you really only see his
lips moving he's muttering something but
you never find out what it is but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Game of
Thrones videos I'm even doing a DVD
giveaway I'll just keep doing that till
we get to season 8 so no worries or when
the book drops the fire and blood book
later this year I'll do it for that so
let's start with the Ned Stark stuff
first because of that Sean Bean clip at
the beginning so he did a couple
separate interviews when he was talking
about Ned Stark
final words he did address the idea that
it had something to do with Lyanna stark
keeping his promise but because Ned
Stark was a devout follower of the old
gods a lot of people were like maybe it
has something to do with that Sean Bean
himself said that in the moment he was
actually trying to be as authentic as
possible because a lot of the structure
of day to day life in the world of the
show is based on medieval life in real
world but while they were filming it
like he himself as the actor couldn't
say anything that was too specific but
goes on to say I don't know if the
religion was around in those days
whatever they were I just thought what
would you do if this were really going
to happen
you would probably pray you would
probably murmur some words and you'd
keep it quiet
you keep it to yourself so his
explanation for what Ned Stark is doing
there is that he's just murmuring a
prayer to the old gods quietly to
himself but the thing about that is
that's just Shawn being the actor's
interpretation of a book moment on the
TV show so that doesn't necessarily
confirm what book Ned Stark is doing in
that moment like maybe he actually is
saying something about Lyanna Stark so
that's still wide open for theory
crafting there's a lot of symbolism and
visual imagery that repeats for
characters and the books that never
really made it to the TV show like
Daenerys seeing the red door over and
over again throughout her adventures but
it is kind of funny of that other
interview how he talks about the TV show
like I haven't really been keeping up
stop watching after I got by headed why
not John Snow for the Iron Throne people
have been asking him about Ned Stark for
years and years and he's like you know
they haven't contacted me about coming
back for any kind of cameos they cut him
into a promo I think it was either for
season 6 or season 7 that just has some
flashback scenes of Ned Stark going into
the iron throne room but unless they
have some crazy twist anymore Ned Stark
flashbacks that we get are probably
going to be Rhaegar and Lyanna specific
meaning that would be a younger version
of the character coming back but I'm not
expecting that because there are only
six episodes so if we do get more
flashbacks they'll probably be specific
to the mythology of the White Walkers
and the night king or two Rhaegar and
Lyanna but as for actual filming right
now a lot of you have asked I haven't
been doing behind-the-scenes videos
because it does kind of get into
spoilers right now what they're doing if
you're wondering there's a bunch of big
green screens up there just filming big
battle scenes with the unsullied which
we all
was going to happen so it's not
revelatory or anything like that most of
you have probably guess the reason for
the really big green screens is just so
it's easier to add the knight King on
Vissarion flying around during the
battle the bigger news I think is all
the extra king's landing sets that
they've built that they've said will
remain after the show's finale so
usually when a TV show is done with a
set they'll tear it down because they
don't need to film scenes there anymore
but sometimes they'll reuse the set for
other productions now they didn't say
they're doing a game of Thrones movie
most people are guessing probably
correctly that they're gonna use this
for the prequel series so we'll actually
get a lot of king's landing during the
prequel series which even though they
haven't confirmed a lot of details about
the prequel series just confirms that
it's gonna be one of the biggest known
ones that we've seen so far so like
dance of the dragons or the Blackfyre
rebellion something that isn't
necessarily completely shackled to the
king's landing location as a set but
something that involves it in a really
big way so this sort of throws out the
idea that they would do a series
completely set in ancient Valyria
even though hopefully we need a prequel
series if it deals more with the history
of the Targaryens we might actually get
some flashbacks to ancient Valyria but
I'm really just taking this to mean that
they're moving closer and closer to
confirming a dance of the Dragons series
there I mean they're a couple different
series that could involve King's Landing
in a big way but Aegon's conquest is
almost too similar to what's happening
on the show right now and it feels like
they want to be as different as possible
while it's still retaining some very
familiar things in dance of the Dragons
just sort of checks all those boxes off
but the really cool thing about the fact
that they film a lot of this outdoors is
it the minute they start filming the
pilot for whatever this prequel series
is going to be we'll have a pretty good
idea where it's set during so that'll
just narrow it way way down but getting
into Georgia our Martin winds of winter
territory so he confirms that there's
not going to be any new readings until
winds of winter drops meaning no new
excerpts if I can find any other videos
of him reading chapters I'll totally
post them because it is fun to watch him
do that but remember that once the book
does drop he will go on the customary
book tour so he'll go back to the
practice of answering really specific
questions like he used to go to
conventions regularly and answer all
kinds of really specific details about
the characters about the dragons without
getting into really crazy spoilers for
stuff down the road
but because the delays between the TV
show in the books became such a big
problem he had to stop doing that so
that's why he hasn't been going around
doing a lot of readings or answering a
lot of questions he also continues to be
mone the fact that the show is moving so
much faster than the books and I know
there's been a lot of speculation about
why they're ending the TV show so soon
but the most part it's Dan and Dave's
choice to end the TV show it's not HBO's
there's a lot of confusion when I see
people comment on this so like how could
HBO cancel Game of Thrones this early it
has nothing to do with HBO they would
love to have 20 seasons of the main show
if they could get that from the
producers the thing that most people
have probably guessed correctly is the
Dana Deaver just getting burnt out on
the series they want to do something
else they just signed on to that big
Star Wars trilogy that they're
developing now so they just want to move
on and have they done a page to screen
adaptation of the books what you would
have had is is like a Walking Dead
situation where you have multiple
different producers take over for
previous show runners you'd also have
that very real problem where the younger
actors would really start aging out of
their roles and it become a real
noticeable problem which is let me know
in the comments what do you think about
Ned Stark's actual final words in the
books and what do you think about the
idea that King's Landing is going to be
a really big location during the prequel
series and what that says about the
actual story that they're going to do so
what will happen is is now that we're
starting to get more and more Game of
Thrones news just as really big stuff
drops I'll do videos for it but leave
all your requests for bonus videos in
the comments below and I'll just name a
new winner when I post new Game of
Thrones so click here for my season 8
playlist and click here for brand-new
Avengers infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you